Ellie Edwards was doing nothing but
enjoying herself on a night out
she was with her sister as they
celebrated bringing in Christmas
together
but it was her who was caught in the
line of Reckless gunfire and murdered
so isn't she yeah with her that night
with Jess and Meg like so many friends
for a girl much loved the loss is
immense we went to go and get a drink
went to the bar and then we just stayed
I just said
people we thought it was fine
automatically everyone just stopped and
we were like
something's not right when they returned
Ellie had been shot in the head and
panicked ensued it was literally within
like it feels like it was as of
everything happening it feels like we we
were so happy and then within us with a
second she was taken and it's just
there's no way yeah so fast that it just
happened like I can't can't get that on
my head yeah she was going home to go to
sleep and wake up on Christmas with her
family it could have been anyone that
night it could it could have been anyone
and where we're very lucky but it
shouldn't have been alive ever it was
only 10 minutes before Christmas Day
when the attack took place
foreign
Ed at least 12 gunshots can be heard
just moments later those who were
celebrating on Christmas Eve are seen
leaving shocked confused and distraught
and within minutes of receiving a call
Emergency Services arrived but by then
police believe the gunman driving a dark
Mercedes had fled
at the scene where she was killed
Ellie's family came to lay flowers for a
Woman They so deeply loved on what was
supposed to be the happiest few days
they've undoubtedly been the worst
as police forensic work at the pub
continues a Manhunt is still underway
the gunman who fired shots at the front
entrance of the lighthouse Inn remains
at large but people around here have
said this kind of violence is unusual in
wallasey and that's a concern it hasn't
ever really um
manifested itself across the river on
the world
um in the way that we've seen
um these kinds of Heartless attacks and
and and behavior of serious organized
crime going on over the other side of
the river and and so I think that that
is also a very worrying development
merseyside police said they will not
rest until they find those responsible
for Ellie's murder and the injuries
sustained by four others a 28 year old
man remains in a critical condition
what is clear from police is that Ellie
who was snatched in the prime of her
life wasn't the intended target she was
an innocent woman caught up in a brutal
incident into man Rashid Sky News the
world